WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS ON THE SUMMIT AND
WHAT COMES NEXT.
GOOD MORNING, JOHN.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU, CHRIS.
TO HEAR PRESIDENT TRUMP TELE,
THE NEXT APP HE HOPES IS THAT
KIM JONG UN WILL START TEARING
DOWN THE NUCLEAR PROGRAM HE JUST
SPENT BILLIONS BUILDING.
BUT THE PRESIDENT'S CRITICS
DOUBT THIS NEW RELATIONSHIP WILL
EVER PAY OFF.
HISTORY BOOKS.
THE FIRST TIME A SITTING U.S.
PRESIDENT HAS MET WITH THE
LEADER OF NORTH KOREA.
THE ROAD TO GET HERE WAS A LONG
ONE.
>> WE WILL HAVE A TERRIFIC
RELATIONSHIP, I HAVE NO DOUBT.
>> THERE WILL BE OBSTACLES ON
THE WAY FORWARD BUT WE OVERCAME
ALL OF THEM.
>> WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS TOLD
FOX NEWS THE ENTIRE SUMMIT WAS
DEPENDENT ON HOW THE FIRST 101
BETWEEN THE LEADERS WOULD GO.
AFTER DECADES OF POLITICAL AND
RHETORICAL CONFLICT BETWEEN THE
TWO NATIONS AND PERSONAL INSULTS
THEY RELET EACH OTHER,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE AND
KIM JONG UN FORMED A PERSONAL
BOND.
>> WE ARE PREPARED TO START A
NEW HISTORY AND WE ARE READY TO
WRITE A NEW CHAPTER BETWEEN OUR
NATIONS.
>> THE SUMMIT ENDED WITH A JOINT
COMMUNIQUE
COMMUNIQUÉ, KIM PLEDGING TO WORK
TOWARDS THE COMPLETE
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE KOREAN
PENINSULA IN EXCHANGE FOR U.S.
SECURITY GUARANTEES.
>> THE WORLD WILL SEE A MAJOR
CHANGE.
>> BUT MISSING FROM THE
DOCUMENT, ANY LANGUAGE ABOUT
VERIFICATION, THE NUTS AND BOLTS
OF HOW THE U.S. WILL ENSURE THAT
KIM IS MAKING GOOD ON HIS
PROMISES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTED THAT
WE'LL ALL BE WORKED OUT.
>> IS GOING TO BE ACHIEVED BY
HAVING A LOT OF PEOPLE THERE,
AND AS WE DEVELOP A CERTAIN
TRUST AND WE ARE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH THEM ON A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS, BUT THIS IS
COMPLETE DENUCLEARIZATION.
>> DEMOCRATS JUMPED ON THE
COMMUNIQUE
COMMUNIQUÉ AS VAGUE AND
TOOTHLESS.
>> KIM JONG UN AND NORTH KOREA
HAVE MADE COMMITMENTS IN THE
PAST THAT THEY HAVE NOT FOLLOWED
PAST THAT THEY HAVE NOT FOLLOWE
FOLLOWED.
MORE SPECIFIC COMMITMENTS THAN
WE HAVE HEARD DURING THIS
SUMMIT.
SO YOU CAN'T TAKE HIS WORD FOR
IT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO HEARD
CRITICISM FOR HIS PLEDGE TO END
U.S.-SOUTH KOREAN JOINT MILITARY
EXERCISES, ALONG A THORN IN
NORTH KOREA'S SIDE, THE
PRESIDENT CALLING THEM
PROVOCATIVE AND EXPENSIVE.
>> NUMBER ONE WE SAVE MONEY, A
LOT, AND NUMBER TWO, IT REALLY
IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK THEY
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
>> TRUMPS EASTWOOD GIVING AWAY
TWO OR THREE OF THE MAJOR THINGS
THAT KIM JONG UN WANTED, A
MEETING, THE FLAGS NEXT TO EACH
OTHER, NOW NO DELAY OF EXERCISES
WITH SOUTH KOREA WITHOUT GETTING
ANYTHING IN RETURN.
>> BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO
FOUND PRAISE FROM BRITISH SOREN
DOMINIC FOREIGN SECRETARY BORIS
JOHNSON WHO SAID IN A STATEMENT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS THE STABILITY OF A
REGION VITAL TO GLOBAL ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID HE
WOULD HAVE GIVEN HIM THE
SECURITY GUARANTEES ALSO SO.
>> I'M A PRETTY HAWKISH GUY, BUT
I'M WILLING TO GIVE HIM SECURITY
GUARANTEES AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY I DON'T THINK I
WOULD HAVE GIVEN A YEAR AGO.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP THE TALES OF
DENUCLEARIZATION, VERIFICATION,,
AND ENTER THE THE WAR AND
POSSIBLE NORMALIZATION OF
RELATIONS WITH THE U.S. WILL ALL
BE WORKED OUT IN MEETINGS WITH
KIM.
THE REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES ARE
URGING HIM TO PROCEED
CAUTIOUSLY.
>> WORKING WITH KIM IS LIKE
TRYING TO HAND FEED SHARK.
YOU CAN DO IT, YOU HAVE TO DO IT
VERY, VERY CAREFULLY.
>> DEMOCRATS ALSO CRITICIZED
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR GIVING
KIM JONG UN THE LEGITIMACY OF A
ONE ON ONE MEETING WITH THE
LEADER OF THE FREE WORLD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO GIVE UP
NOTHING OTHER THAN A COUPLE OF
DAYS TRAVEL AND SAYS HE WAS
HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH KIM IF IT
WOULD GO SOME DISTANCE TO SAVING
THE LIVES OF THE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS
WOULD LIKELY BE KILLED IN A